hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that happened today in
the super bet uh Blitz tournament uh
it's the first day of Blitz and it's
Wesley so versus anijigiri now now this
game was sent to me by ozarov he said it
was an incredible game an immortal one
if you will and okay we have to be very
careful when we call a game Immortal
when uh we're discussing Blitz because I
I mean it's blitz so you know anything
can happen uh but it's uh so the game is
so enjoyable that we could call like a
mini Blitz Immortal game now uh and I I
imagine that uh anisha's he's
um a very active and just about he's
creating courses that uh you know
playing games like these really uh makes
a difference and really you know uh
improves the the sales and his
adjustable courses and now you'll see
what I mean by this uh let's check it
out Wesley has the white pieces and he
opens with Ponte E4 and yes we do have
the ceiling defense as you guys probably
already imagine Pawn to see five Knight
F3 D6 and now Bishop to B5 Wesley goes
for the canal attack uh and the bishop
to D7 is the most common way to handle
it here we have Knight the D7 by a niche
we have D4 Wesley strikes in the center
C character Sunday for and now you don't
have to worry about the Knight attacking
the queen when you recapture in the
center with the queen like it would for
example in the night of you can simply
capture with the queen and the queen is
now very nicely centralized uh Ponte A6
with Bishop act E2 and now Knight G2 F6
and he's just continuous development we
have castles and Ponte E5 now Chase is
away the queen and you have to keep the
queen somewhere defending the E4 pawning
the E3 square is the best for that so
Knight to C5 now attacking the E4 pawn
and now Knight the C3 uh now the pawn is
nicely defended and just Bishop to E7
Anish now says I might uh even be
interested in castling here and though
I'm sure you guys are thinking let's
just kick away that Knight with Ponte B4
well this is one of those positions
where B4 will not in fact Grant you uh
and uh you know upper hand because after
Knight E6 is just uh really really great
for black and B4 doesn't seem to
complement White's position all that
much so instead we have Pawn to A4 uh
stopping B5 and now uh we have castles
and this is a new move in the position
there is a known uh Knight the G4
attacking the queen which was played in
2017 between
the game ended in a draw but here we
have Castles by Anish and it is now
as of move tender we have a completely
new game so Wesley continues uh with
knights the D2 now he might even have
some ideas of advancing the F Pawn also
the Knight can now come to see for maybe
in the future to E3 to D5 maybe you can
gain control more control over the D5
square but Knights the G4 attacking the
queen and now we have a trade captures
captures and now upon the H3 with Bishop
back D6 and pawn to B3 and it seems like
um uh Wesley uh fixed all of his uh
positional problems uh but it's not as
clear Rook to C8 now the Knight on C3
has been weakened with Bishop to B2 and
now Pawn to F5 and you really can't be
all that happy with white here I mean
you you should always have some sort of
a small edge with white but here you
just don't uh don't feel it white
doesn't have any of the uh usual ideas
here you don't have F4 at any point you
don't really gain anything by putting a
knight to D5 uh C3 has already been
weakened and
um yeah Anish still has the bishop pair
the Rooks are excellently placed and see
it and their fate the Knight is
beautiful on C5 so if anyone is to be
preferred here it is um definitely black
whether it's any sort of real Advantage
it's probably merely uh easier to play
this with black so here you don't want
to capture if you trade it then you give
black too much central control also now
the C2 Pawn will become very weak so
instead we have Rook F to D1 by Wesley
and now Pawn to F4 Anish continues
advancing his pawn queen to E2 and now
Queen to E8 saying that he wants to
bring the queen over to G6 and prepare
Pawn to F3
uh so here Ponte F3 would probably be
the safest move to play but Wesley goes
Knight to the D5 and usually if you can
land the Knight on D5 uh against uh the
zillion that your life will be good but
if black can just trade without any uh
problems then uh should be should be
great for black so here Bishop captures
on the 5e characters on D5 and queen to
G6 now okay you don't really have F3 as
the Knight is guarding the F3 square but
you have to be very very careful here
Queen to G4 is the move you should play
uh and uh you know just offer a queen
trade whether black will uh accept or
not probably black will capture the C2
Pawn but it's just something that you
have to do then maybe bishop day three
and you play this weird weird position
but black will always be better however
here Wesley played Pawn to B4 which is a
move that almost always works and almost
always improves uh White's position but
that is no uh case here and here Anish
has a brilliant brilliant um uh you know
uh maneuver in the position so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the absolute best move for a niche while
I give you a couple of seconds uh I
think uh you know Fisher is the game of
the century while you are solving this
one uh have at it
foreign
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on finding this
mysterious maneuver and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Knight captures on A4 alright Fisher
didn't capture an A4 in his game of the
century but he did offer a night a full
night on a form so that's why I thought
you guys might pick up on that but the
idea is that now you are yeah you will
win two pawns for the piece and you will
also have incredible pressure on the
position but the real reason why you why
you're doing it is because Rook captures
on C2 will come with Tempo and then you
will be able to play F3 without the
Knight being able to move that's that's
an issue's idea behind the Knight
captures on A4 so you have to capture
there's really nothing better Rook
captures on A4 Rook captures on C2 also
comes with an attack on the bishop so
now you are ready to execute F3 Bishop
to C1 and now Pawn to F3 attacking the
queen and also Checkmate is being
threatened on G2 Queen to F1 only move
that saves the game and now Bishop to H4
and here it's just to really really hard
to find the playable move for Wesley for
example if Ponte G4 looks like you might
be able to play this just Rook to F4 and
now uh not a lot to do here E4 E3 is
coming also Rook captures on G4 in some
lines is just a terrible position for
white uh instead Pawn to G3 was played
but now uh Anish just continues happily
sacrificing Bishop captures on G3 F
captures and now Pawn to E4 here
uh the the you know the the Barbarian
move Queen captures on G3 that pretty
much everyone would play is uh in fact
the the only winning move here and I
will just show it because it's such a
fun line uh but for a Blitz game I I
would say impossible to calculate
because look at this queen captures and
G3 check King H1 and now you have to
play Rook to F6 of course you want to go
for Rook to H6 and Rook captures uh on
H3 if ever Queen to G1 or the queen
moves from the defense of the H3 Pawn
you're just gonna play Queen captures on
H3 so here white would have to find Pawn
to B5 which uh gains access to H4 and
now after Rook to H6 Pawn to H4 Rook
captures an H4 with check Rook captures
Queen captures with check and now after
King to G1 uh this spectacular Ponte F2
check now who finds this in a Blitz game
I do not know but it is incredible and
now yeah if you capture with the queen
then just Queen to G4 check picks up the
Rook on D1 and of course if King to G2
doesn't really matter you're gonna play
Rook to C3 and now there's no defense
against Rook to G3 whatever you play
with the queen to H1 Rook the G3 with
checking captures and F2 and now Rook
the H3 opens up a discovery and wins the
White Queen so I mean uh that's a brutal
but uh it is blitz so Point F4 was
played by a niche and now uh uh Rook to
A3 Knight captures an E4 sort of still
holds but uh I mean it doesn't hold it
loses the game but it is the best way uh
to defend you know give back some
material get rid of those pawns but in
the game Rook the A3 was played and now
comes Queen captures on G3 with check
King to H1 and now Rook F the C8 by
Anish uh Rook F6 the H6 is still
perfectly fine uh as okay the bishop is
here but if the knight ever moves you're
just gonna get the Checkmate it's all
Rook to F6 still works here Anisha opts
for Rook F to C8 and now we have Queen
to G1 offering a queen trade uh but uh
and also hoping for Queen captures on H3
even though this is also winning but
Anish plays an even greater move and
that is Rook captures and C1 he sort of
sacrifices the queen but if you take the
queen uh you just lose all of the
material for example Queen captures and
G3 Queen Rook capture Sandy one with
checking H2 now the Knight Falls with
check knocking goes back Rook the C1
check and now you have to part with the
queen as well Queen to G1 you can even
play Rook D to D1 and that's pretty much
it Queen captures The Rook captures okay
now uh both players have a rook but
black is up there are four pawns so
we're not going to discuss this any
further so I have to Rook captures and
C1 Rook the A1 was played but it is
merely prolonging the game Queen
captures an H3 with check Queen to H2 we
have Queen captures and H2 with check
King captures and now Rook captures on
A1 Rook captures on A1 and now Rook the
C2 and he was in this position on move
32 uh that uh Wesley Seoul resigned in
the the game as there is nothing more to
be done here Anisha wins a spectacular
spectacular game and like I said I
imagine his adjustable course sales are
going through the roof now as he does
have some you know insights to offer on
the Sicilian Defense uh so yeah here we
resign because you will also lose the
Knight and then you I mean the pawns are
just Unstoppable you can try to defend
but they need three and the Knight
cannot move of course once the king
moves you're even gonna play Rook
capture Sunday to threaten The Rook
white can never trade here once The Rook
moves uh you're just gonna play F2 and
of course a black is completely winning
you have too much material
uh so brilliant game by Anish uh Wesley
also played an incredible game but uh I
mean uh it was uh it's hard to say if it
was a more difficult to defend this
position or to find uh all the winning
ideas that were were present in this
position but yeah I mean uh that's why
um I I thought that you guys would
figure out the winning idea if I
mentioned Bobby Fisher's game of the
century Knights the A4 uh but yeah
sometimes uh even if you even if you
can't calculate maybe just knowing about
the game of the century will give you uh
maybe an idea to try and sacrifice the
Knight on A4 and then you know
everything just starts happening all at
once but yeah you know you have to pin
the Knight on D2 to gain access the F3
and then I mean of course you can
calculate all of this but uh you know
you you go with the flow and you know
you feel good and good things happen
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by Anisha
after nine rounds of Blitz Duda is still
leading but Magnus caught up to him
Magnus is only uh trailing by half a
point and I believe Magnus won like six
of his last games that he played uh I
can't even check I don't want to trick
you guys uh let me just check real
quickly uh there we go
uh so let's check the standings
uh yeah dude is leading with 17 and a
half points Magnus trailing with 17
points followed by Wesley saw with 16
and a half points so if uh and you
didn't play This brilliant game against
Wesley Wesley would be co-leading with
the Duda but there you have it then you
have in Fort Levon with 16 uh MBL with
15 and a half at Upward with 13 and a
half on Niche with 10 and a half uh
Daniel Dak with nine and a half and so
nine and a half has a kilochenko in that
so there you have it those were the
standings we'll see what happens in day
two will Magnus continue his Onslaught
or will Duda be able to remain in the
lead uh we'll see what happens
definitely uh in an exciting tournament
but uh I'm I am of course hoping for
more games like these uh so yeah that
the game really hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank John shortcliffe
golfsoftware.com Paul hinamund revision
reptiles YouTube and Goran wodopia for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continue in the coverage of
everything that's happening in the Chess
World and of course checking up on your
wonderful suggestions uh so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day